triste spectacle les feuilles mortes
santa sur ces courts de tennis vide
depuis des semaines le président du club
christian mouvaux ne peut que le
constater la crise sanitaire a entraîné
une chute du nombre de licenciés une
cinquantaine de licenciés en moins
c'est-à-dire à peu près 25 pour cent de
perte par rapport à la saison dernière
beaucoup de parents aient hésité à
remettre leurs enfants à l'école de
tennis est ce que ça va durer ça va se
prolonger
on sait pas exactement où il ya une
crainte ya une certaine peur c'est ce
qui est légitime d'ailleurs
installations fermé et inaccessible
compétition suspendu le confinement
n'incite pas à prendre une licence à
quelques dizaines de mètres à la piscine
est elle aussi bien vide
excepté pour les scolaires et les
sportifs de haut niveau elle est fermée
au public
ce matin-là une seule nageuse s'entraîne
avec son coach en premier et je vais
chercher devant soit pas trop sur dû
rattraper devant thomas pinel est l'un
des deux entraîneurs salariés à temps
plein du club
ici le nombre de licenciés est passé de
900 à 600 or les cotisations restent la
principale source de revenus
ça fait 300 licences a en moyenne 170
euros
donc ça finances limite les mon salaire
à l'année et
et une partie d'un autre donc nous on
est en étant trois salariés ça fait
quand même beaucoup et ça met un peu en
péril la vie associative du club
l'épidémie met à genoux l'ensemble du
monde sportif amateur président de
l'omnisports fade auxerrois thierry
renault est à la tête de 17 sections et
de près de 3000 licenciés pour lui le
pire est peut-être à venir si on n'a pas
de rentrées financières
on pourra pas vivre c'est même si l'état
aide on pourra pas on pourra pas
finaliser les choses quoi si ça dure
vraiment vraiment trop longtemps il ya
sûrement des sections qui vont qui vont
disparaître voire peut-être même plus
que des sections voix stades piscines
courts de tennis rien ne devrait rouvrir
avant l'année prochaine
reste à savoir combien de clubs amateurs
seront encore debout